LeBron and Savannah I don't know there's  like some picture of LeBron like looking  real happy with the side chick right I'm  pretty sure I don't know be bad for  their brand  um they are they are  um this is a hard one because there are  some reports that I guess like she maybe  not isn't the best at home like I've  heard that but I've also I also feel  like LeBron doesn't want to get divorced  like I feel like a LeBron it's just not  good for like his brand is kind of like  the family man so I I just think he has  too much and I think he would if it  wasn't for like the brand and I think  that some people the brand is more  important than the relationship like  Hillary and Bill you know so I think  they're gonna stay together for the  brand